- If we're gonna be miserable,
at least we're being miserable together.
I think that's actually the best
summary of Game of Thrones.
- Yeah.
(Game Of Thrones-style music)
- We're here to play
Fuck, Marry, Red Wedding
with the Game of Thrones characters
a.k.a. fuck Khal Drogo, kill Boltons
- And marry Robb Stark.
- I have a feeling we're here
to make a lot of really tough decisions.
- Tough decisions?
Oh they'll be pretty easy for me, I think.
- I want to both marry
and be Daenerys Targaryen.
- I can safely say Tywin.
He's a man with a plan.
And I gotta have a man with a plan.
And a man with a lotta money.
- Jon Snow is my favorite
Game of Thrones character.
He's still on the market.
- We don't really need Jon Snow.
I feel like he's just there,
stirring up a bunch of crap.
- I think he's a little overrated.
- Okay, yeah I think he's overrated.
- I'm so ready.
- All men must die.
- Winter is here.
- [Voice] We're the Dead Dads
'cuz everyone's dad is dead.
- Well this is easy.
Kill Robert Baratheon.
Kill him like a wild boar.
I would love to marry or have relations
With Khal Drogo, I think.
- Marry Ned Stark.
I think we all know what happens to him.
I mean, he's a good man.
- I don't wanna end up like Cersei.
- Yeah, no.
- No.
- I would probably go a little crazy
if I was married to Robert Baratheon.
- [Voice] Yass, powerful women!
- Wait, no, this is hard!
I love them all, can I marry them all?
- I'd kill Cersei because she's a moron.
- I don't want to fuck her either,
but I also feel like she would know
some crazy shit in bed,
I'm still gonna kill her.
- Before I "red wedding" her,
I wanna have a glass of
wine with her, have a gab.
- Then I would fuck Margaery, because
She's hot, she's young, perfect.
- And you could eff
her brother afterwards.
- Oooh, yassss.
- Okay, nerd alert here.
There should be an "e" in my wife's name.
- Daenerys, she knows what she's doing.
I'll fuck her.
- See, I'm gonna marry Daenerys,
because I don't wanna be one
of Daenerys's side pieces.
- [Voice] Oh my God,
this is the easiest one.
- Well it is pretty,
one of the easiest ones.
I'm not gonna lie, I don't
really know who this was.
- Wait, Ed Sheeran?
Well I already know who I'm gonna kill
and I haven't even looked
at the other two people.
- Wow.
- I love how Ed Sheeran is in here.
Oh my god, I love you.
- That was ridiculous.
- Fuck Theon Greyjoy, obviously
Pre-Ramsay Bolton.
- And be his last?
- Yeah, I mean
- Go out with a bang?
(laughs)
- Ooh, I'm gonna marry Robb,
Even though he's a little idealistic
And probably wouldn't
keep us alive very well
But he's so cute.
- I'm more into Ned Stark than I am Robb,
But, you know, I'll take him.
- [Voice] Oh no, oh no!
Not the Freys.
- Oh my god, this is so
- Joffrey, Joffrey?
Just kill all of them!
- I know!
Can we put them all right here?
- Kill all of them.
Kill every single one of them.
- This one's horrible!
What a horrible,
what, why?
- Yeah, this one's impossible.
- I would kill Walder Frey again and again
and again and again.
- Joffrey even fuck anyone?
- I wouldn't call what any of these men do
with women "fucking."
- They don't all fit!
- I definitely wouldn't kill Frey
because I know that he's gonna die anyway.
He probably can't even get it up.
- Judging by the size of his family,
it looks like he can.
- This game has just taught me
that most of people on Game
of Thrones are terrible people
that you would never want to
do any of those things with.
- Have any association.
- The show's complicated.
The decisions we made
today are complicated.
But, that's how I feel about the show.
It's conflicting and I like that.
- I just wish I could've
killed Joffrey and Ramsay.
No one would ever be like,
"you know where I wanna live?"
"Westeros."
- [Voice] No.